وفي ظهورهما معنا امام الكاميرات اكد
الرئيس الامريكي جو باردن وضيفه الرئيس
الفرنسي
عمق العلاقات بين بلديهما
باريس على مواجهه التحديات مشيرا الى
انهما سيناقشان التعاون في مجال الطاقه
اما ماكرون فقال ان هناك عده خلافات سيتم
البحث في كيفيه تجاوزها اضافه الى مناقشه
الملف الغربي
القصوى حاليا وهو جامكا
انرجي
منها طاقه والاقتصاد ونوويه والفضاء وقد
تحدثت على اعاده التوافق والتنسيق المشترك
واعتقد ان هذا مهم جدا ليكون لدينا تنسيق
كبير بيننا لاننا نريد ان نصلح العواقب
المباشره والغير مباشره للحرب على
اقتصاداتنا وعلى شعوبنا وفي نفس الوقت
نريد التحضير للاشيال القادمه
[موسيقى]
كان هذا ما حدث امام الكاميرات اليوم لكن
لن نعود للامس فالعشاء بين الزعيمين يبدو
انه لم يراب صدعا كان قد كتب فصلا في فطور
الصداقه بينهما 40 عاما هذا هو الفرق بين
الثماني ومكرون الاربعيني الى ان لهما
اخيرا ان يلتقي معا لوقت اطول يسمح لهما
بمناقشته بعضها متفق عليه والاخر بدل
باريس وكانه يحمل ابتزازا لاوروبا باكملها
في استقبال حاولت امريكا جاهده ان تجعله
نوعيا لكون مكروه اول رئيس يخصه بايضا
بمثل هذه المراسم وبادق تفاصيلها من
الثقافيه والتاريخيه الى اختيار الاماكن
التي يجلسون فيها وصولا الى
مائده الطعام الذي صممت خصيصا لتلك
الزياره اطباقها واستراحات من الوان علم
البلدين ومن مكونات معروفه في تقاليد
شعبين مرت مئه عام على علاقتهما لكن كل
ذلك راويه لم ينجح في اخفاء التباين الذي
بات ليس ملحوظا فحسب وانما دفع صحيفه
ليموند الفرنسيه الى وصف مكروم في هذه
الزياره بالمهاجم الشرس بس اوروبا لي
س للتحديدا حينما فتح مكروم قلبه
للبرلمانيين خلال غدا عمل مع الكونجرس ثم
الاموره باسمائها بقوانين بايضا لتعزيز
الصناعه الامريكيه معتبره ان اجراءات
النزعه الحمائيه شديده العدوانيه وقالها
بصراحه ربما تقومون بحل مشكلتكم لكنكم
تفاقمون مشكلتي
فانه حينما زار سفاره بلاده في واشنطن غير
بعضا من الكلمات ليصفها هذه المره
بالاجراءات المفتته للغربه
[موسيقى]
امريكا
كلمه الا والقاها في الارجاء تصدرها الدعم
لاوكرانيا وتداعيات الازمه التي سببتها
تلك الحرب خاصه وان اوروبا
وثمن اكبر مقارنه بامريكا وانا اوروبا
تواجه خطر التخلف عن الركب اذا نجحت
الاعانات المقدمه بموجب القانون الامريكي
في جذب استثمارات جديده
وفرنسا تحديدا ضحيه للتنافس التجاري
الراهن بين واشنطن وبكين اكبر قوتين
اقتصاديتين في العالم
يا اخي
[موسيقى]
وتعبيره
القائد المدافع عن اوروبا والمحافظ على
تاريخ الحلفاء لقدومه الى مقبره الينكتون
الوطنيه والمثقف بعلم الكواكب هكذا حاول
ان يبدو في الزياره التي ذهب خلالها ايضا
الى مقر وكاله ناسا للفضاء
شدد على ضروره تكاتف واشنطن وباريس معا
لمواجهه ما وصفه بالدول المارقه والهجمات
الهجينه
اذا مكروه اوصل رسالته في هذه الزياره لكن
ماذا عن بيضن الذي يداري الاختلاف بلبقه
800 الى تقويه العلاقات مع الشركاء
التقليديين للولايات المتحده وبينهم
الحليف الاقدم وهي الصيغه التي تطلقها
امريكا على فرنسا
مع استراليا وبريطانيا وحينها حرمت فرنسا
من صفقه الغواصات
يبذل قصار جهده لاسترضاء مكروم في هذه
الزياره وفق محللين اضافه الى ان بيض يريد
ان يوحد صفوف البلدين حول موقفهما بشان
الصين حيث ان وعشان تريد ان يشاطرها
الاوروبيون بشكل اكبر قلقها حياله تصعد
قوه بكين في كل المجلات
في توطيد العلاقات اتخذت امريكا اسلوب
المدح حيث قال الناطق باسم من مجلس الامن
القومي في البيت الابيض ان فرنسا تشكل احد
الخيوط التي نسجت بين دولتين كما وعدنا
على الحس القيادي لمكرو وخبرته وحكمته